torment scandal and intrigue the bolshoy
is a ballet company trying to move on
from a dark past in 2013 its previous
ballet director Sergei fillin he was
nearly blinded with acid in an attack
organized by a principal dancer pavel
dmitrichenko a court heard was
supposedly denied key roles by filling
he was motivated heard by hatred and was
jailed for six years since that attack
both Sergei fillin and the Bolshoi's
general director have left the theater
cellino but he brought upon
unfortunately under the previous
leadership there was very much an
atmosphere of sickness here people were
thinking all the time about that and not
about the ballet this is a rehearsal of
Ivan the Terrible a ballet about one of
Russia's most ruthless leaders
surrounded by enemies it's about
politics power and sex things that have
plunged the Bolshoi into scandal
offstage in recent years and which the
new director will be trying to leave
maha Vasya is a political outsider to
the bolshoy and has worked in st.
Petersburg and Milan he's got the job re
energizing one of russia's greatest
ballet companies dollars me I would've
missed use in your man said we should
work together to help the dancers and
create the conditions to let them show
their talent and move forward he's the
crisis de moi is there a system now
where any dancer can show what they can
do what your mug alidium thou should not
get me for you you had lots of myths and
legends the problem is that this is a
huge ballet company which has its own
rhythm I say to all the artists if you
want to show me something I'll very
happily watch it delco initial setup in
philly 0 released as soon as mr. rajeev
arrived everyone mobilized he looks at
everyone and gives everyone a chance to
show what they can do and I think this
is right is that the great discipline
the truth there wasn't this level of
discipline in the past I see now the
people trying really hard the halls have
stopped being practically empty as it
was before everyone is trying to prepare
something
in the past it seems like dancers felt
there was a lot of competition and
internal struggle how does the casting
system work now Jim Boyce of notary can
query on sea star away competition with
any company is a great thing the more
healthy competition there is the better
a ballet company where talent is not the
main criteria is a doomed company and we
have a great company here it doesn't
mean there aren't any problems in fact
there are lots and lots of problems but
the more problems there are the more
interesting it is in Russia the problems
of the bolshoy have not affected its
popularity it is theatergoers say a
palace of culture where the country
shows exactly what it means to be
Russian scandal or no scandal
you